jetpacks real-life Iron Man jetpacks
oh my god every single person who has
flown today has not hovered yet I will
hover I will
I have always been in love with flying
the dream of flying through the sky and
as a kid I wanted to be a fighter pilot
as an adult I got into racing drones
because when this thing is going through
the air from my perspective it actually
looks like I am the one flying doing
flips diving down buildings doing all
kinds of crazy acrobatics but this is
still a proxy for actual flight my body
is still tethered to the earth but what
if I could fly so we're here in
Camarillo at the air 7 hangar because
we're looking at an actual jetpack
[Music]
this is Richard browning who spent the
last several years developing and
inventing the jet suit he's got a whole
TED talk talking about that process I
got invited by a man named Sam who's an
engineer for this company called gravity
and gravity is making jetpacks real-life
Iron Man jetpacks I made it gonna
carries with the past graphs you may
have seen these jetpacks before on
Instagram the videos have been blown up
Adam Savage even made a whole Iron Man
video with the jetpack coming into today
I didn't know what to expect I was like
oh I'll get to see it I don't get to
hang out and then they're like oh so you
wanna learn how to fly it was like I
mean I can actually put the suit on and
try to fly that's pretty freakin sweet
man
like the fact that that exists at all
like we always dreamed about jetpacks as
a kid you know it's like someday we'll
all have jetpacks and fly around because
it's the future or the futures now I
have no idea how hard it's gonna be to
learn how to fly Sam how do you think
you're doing it's like it's like once
you do it once you will not want to get
up
it's just inexplicably like a strange
sensation having so much power I have
confidence I'm gonna nail this first
take first try however I think the
reality is that it's not gonna be that
way so we'll see I'm gonna be here until
I learn how to hover that is my goal
I will hover let's go ahead and talk to
Sam is one of the engineers on this
jetpack and actually learn how this
thing was built and how it works this is
all 3d printed in nylon and aluminium
here it's 5 micro gas turbines that you
put on your body two on each arm and on
the back is one larger entity you end up
as kind of a tripod of thrust and you're
just using your body so you get to
redirect those engines and redistribute
that thrust to allow you to move around
so if you imagine leaning on a table
like that that's as hard as it is yeah I
already know how to fly exact so is
there like a throttle for each arm
individually as you bring that in like
that will increase the the throttle of
the engines but we always fly at full
power we'll bring that trigger into full
power for your body weight and you'll be
able to hold it out there like that and
then only when you vector those down the
throttles staying the same on all those
engines will you then take off its
throttle controlled by moving around as
fast as you can move your arms as fast
as you can change your thrust going
downwards technically I'll give you some
ear defenders because it is extremely
loud
leading loud
so when I first started it was at the
stage of kind of a prototype we're just
experimenting with 3d printing some
parts but it was made from available
parts that we assembled together it's
just about trying something as quickly
as possible seeing if it works and then
either ditching it or going with it it's
cool with a project like this that it
doesn't have like a formal purpose or
exact application so I want to try and
make it look as close to a sci-fi movie
as possible and the next thing I'm
working on at the moment actually is
just for fun is the visor that goes
bitching looks like that I guess Ren's
out at the runway right now and they're
gonna let him fly this jetpack suit
thing and you know knowing Ren he don't
worry about that it's just Jarvis
he's an adjutant instead Jarvis I
thought it would be good to take this
opportunity before anything happens and
just go through and update it's just in
case his wife he's just in case
Jarvis stopped what's a just in case
have I not talked to you about this is
part of the employee ID handbook when I
gave out I have I have just in case
websites for everyone in the studio in
case why don't you just guess what just
in case you die I'm so different so
anyway using today's sponsor Squarespace
I made a just in case you die website
for everybody and I thought it'd be a
good chance to update Ren's everyone
will be able to go to this website and
find out how right find out how here
there's a button Ren you were a really
nice person you always had a smile on
your face Billy my Billy Boy you always
wanted to fly so high he did love
hotdogs
he loved hotdogs I mean that would be a
great one so the first thing that
Squarespace does that I really like is a
thing called simultaneous posting we can
post one time on the website and it will
automatically format and post to his
Twitter and Facebook profiles now the
only thing I have to do is get his
password I told you about the Justin
case
thing that I was updating for Ren right
yeah just in case yeah yeah just in case
you know I need his Twitter password do
you have it
Ren's Twitter password yeah I don't
think the next thing that we can do if
Ren has an ultimate oopsie
is I figured we could have a podcast in
his memory using squarespace's audio box
tool we'll be able to host the audio
from that podcast on to our Squarespace
website and have it automatically go out
as an RSS feed to wherever we want it to
go and I wanted to know if you guys
could do the podcast with me okay I
would be honored just in case I am
curious to see my just in case basically
every Monday I go in and I update them
just based on what I know people are
working on that week Jarvis open open
the mask Jarvis 1/3 cool thing about
Squarespace is that allows you to have
multiple contributors to a website so
all you do is go under your management
tools and you can add new people that
have different types of access to your
site it's a really helpful tool
yo-dee-hey man I was had to hit publish
on you when you fell if you're one way
all the other day didn't I yeah so my
life flashed before my eyes yeah I know
that just in case that's what we build
them right yeah do you think that just
in case if I die that you could post on
Ren's site and let everyone know using
multiple contributors I could do that
okay so anyway if you guys are
interested in head on over to
Squarespace calm slash corridor crew and
you'll get 10% off the purchase of your
first website or domain remember just in
case use Squarespace
some people are having some trouble
actually learning how to fly it's taking
them quite a bit of effort you have two
minutes to kind of just like bounce
around and kind of like learned how it
affects you now I'm having to go at the
end of the line here because the guys
who are flying right now are actually
paying the fly so that guy was the vice
president of the bomb kills every single
person who has flown today has not
hovered yet not a single person is
hovered it's making me a little
concerned I like to think that I have a
good sense of balance and athleticism
but there's no reason to say that these
guys don't logically understand that I
have to kind of make myself a tripod
lock my arms any amount before that's
gonna be I have to make sure that I'm
like very steady and it's gonna be
squishy and I just kind of kind of learn
how it pushes me around before I
actually get to a point right go up I'm
scrapping any sort of expectation that
I'll actually be able to take off on my
first try that's just not gonna happen I
say that now I'm obviously totally gonna
try to take off a little bit on my first
try but we'll see I might totally ruin
it I don't know adds a certain point is
like I'm not gonna get apply all right
we got two more clients and then you'll
be the last flight of the day I was like
I'm gonna get to fly it's a special
heat-resistant material this is what we
like you to wear underneath just to
protect your skin all right done I
already know how to fly it I'll just
snip the cable and fly away you psyched
I'm everything you got you dude you lift
these things up and you're gonna go
backwards so just like kind of like a
mime kind of like this feel it out as
Richard said it's like oddly calm but
like crazy so after this guy
so you ready my gosh yes
which they relaxed that's the key I'm
like going through an Ironman suit up
sequence right now
nope you ready these are heavy okay if
you head off to the state
help
dude I was amazing dude I could feel I
could just like I'm on a little squishy
cloud I feel like Goku man like riding a
Nimbus it felt like balancing on top of
like a ball but you're vectoring on that
first one like you completely understood
that wait till it powers up out here
then bring it down you have super
comfortable there that was the best
first guy and his just ability to
maintain disability was like the best
they're letting me try again because I
actually came pretty close to hovering I
think you could offer you think so yeah
I think so maybe now continue doing
those jumps into the air with slightly
more power they'll start you slightly
below what you just ended on
[Music]
that was so good very impressive that's
so good that's so great
I was flying there for a moment you've
now joined a very very small number of
people who have managed to hover on the
second go like super impressive my
shoulders are exhausted now though dude
it's all that beat sabre training and
allowed me to do this at all that was
one of the most satisfying experiences
of my life to be completely honest it's
also slightly disappointing because I
feel I can do so much better just with a
little bit more practice but this is not
one of those things that you can just
buy at a store and practice on so I feel
very humbled to have even had this
opportunity
what's going on we heard a lot of how
these little like challenge coins you
know it's kind of an American tradition
yeah so you you qualify there is there
is a coin there is the flight experience
one now pretty unusually and
ridiculously in to goes usually I mean
you do really well if you get in five or
six but you didn't - so there is a
silver one which is pretty special that
weighs like that like one and now I'm
going to tease you and show you the gold
one there is the gold one which is the
one that you get when you kind of
pre-flight so next time someday though
not even someday I think you work really
good so I won't be long for you one of
those thank you dude guys this has been
great take on gravity is such a special
company you know they're constantly
improving the jet pack they're
constantly going to these events to
actually show off flying around the best
way for you to see what they're all up
to is to follow them on Instagram take
on gravity and and who knows maybe we'll
actually do something together again
this year absolutely consider
subscribing for maybe some of that in
the future I think we got I think we got
some some cool stuff ahead of you
especially this racing drum imagine if
this thing shot Nerf darts subscribe